the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for my Game of
Thrones Season eight episode 2 breakdown
video today I want to go through each of
the scenes from the episode then give
you my thoughts on the scene and even my
expectations for the future let's start
at the beginning of the episode where we
can see Jaime Lannister is getting
questioned by Daenerys Targaryen as you
all know Jaime Lannister has shown up in
Winterfell because he does want to help
them defeat the army of the dead in the
last season Cersei Lannister also agreed
to help but she later revealed to Jaime
that she actually lied right to
everyone's face she doesn't give a damn
about the army of the Dead Cersei
actually hopes they invade the north
because she thinks they will defeat our
enemies for her but what she doesn't
understand is if that happens they're
also gonna come down and kill everyone
in King's Landing Jaime understood this
he does not want to die but he also
wants to keep his word he said he would
help so that's exactly what he's gonna
do now he's in Winterfell but they were
not very happy to see him show up all
alone they were all assuming the
Lannisters would show up with a very big
army now although they all know the
Lannisters cannot be trusted
Daenerys kept getting reassurance from
Tyrion Lannister when Jaime reveals that
Cersei lied that causes Dany to
immediately start to question Tyrion
judgment and even his allegiance this is
something Dany has had to question a lot
lately she's starting to get the sense
that maybe it's time to start to really
look into Tyrians intentions but let's
get to that later
Jaime also has some explaining to do
even though John and Danny went down to
King's Landing to get Cersei and Jaime's
help Danny wants to take the opportunity
to let Jamie know just how much she
hates him after all Jaime is responsible
for killing Danny's father the Mad King
now Danny does know her father was crazy
but he is still our father regardless
Jaime killing the Mad King was one of
the things that led to Daenerys and her
brother having to flee from Dragonstone
in the middle of the night otherwise
they would have been killed just like
Rhaegar and Elias children were killed
by the mountain this was why Oberyn
agreed to be Tyrion champion during his
trial by combat
and what about what I want justice
for my sister and her chica if you want
justice you've come to the wrong place
I disagree he wanted vengeance for his
dead sister Anna's dead niece and nephew
who just so happened to be Jon Snow's
brother and sister because of Danny's
father getting killed and their army
getting beat at the battle at the
Trident Daenerys had to spend most of
her life on the run over in Essos now
she finally has the chance to speak to
one of the men that led to her family
losing the Iron Throne so like I said
Danny may know that her father did
deserve to die but that doesn't mean her
and Jaime should automatically become
best friends
this man is hated throughout most of
Westeros even more so in the north
his family is responsible for Ned
Stark's execution the tragedy at the red
wedding and even brands start getting
crippled also you can't blame one of
them for thinking Jaime might stab them
in the back literally and figuratively
this is why I was hoping brain stark
would tell everyone the truth about
Jaime killing the Mad King bran saw
exactly what happened inside of the
weirwood net now I did like that Brienne
stood up for Jaime that makes sense for
her to do that but I was also hoping
that bran would say something as well
bran all be asleep wanted Jaime to live
because he says as much later when
they're talking out in the godswood
either way I am very happy that they let
Jaime join the fight this is how I
wanted this scene to end however this
did leave Danny in a very uncomfortable
spot she was basically one of the only
ones hesitating to let Jamie into their
service but she was outnumbered
Danny's right-hand man Tyrion said they
can trust Jaime Brienne more or less
said Jaime is no longer the same man
that he was I give you my word then
Songza said she trusted Brienne and jon
said they need all the men they can get
this was interesting because Danny is
the queen she is sitting right at the
head of the table she was the one asking
Jaime the questions for the most part
but everyone around her basically said
you know what it's fine Jaime can come
kick it with us when Danny wanted john
to give his opinion she was hoping Jon
would say something in her defense she
did not want Jamie to be accepted so
easily but Jon already went down to
King's Landing to get them to help in
the first place regardless of what Jaime
did years ago Jon wanted in need
him there so Jamie gets his Valyrian
steel sword handed back to him from grey
worm and I do have to say if looks could
kill Jamie would have been dead
grey worm does not like Jamie you could
see that he was basically feeding off of
Danny's energy the grey worm knows that
Danny may have submitted but she is not
happy about it then Danny goes to look
at John wondering what the hell just
happened here but John walks away
immediately he doesn't even want to make
eye contact John still has a lot to
think about
he knows him and Danny are related and
he knows he is first in line for the
Iron Throne something danny has wanted
for a very long time now as everyone
walks out of the room Danny says
something to Tyrion that may be
foreshadowing his fate Cersei is still
sitting on the Iron Throne if Tyrion
cannot help Danny get it back then she's
gonna find someone else that can he says
I suspect someone else will be wearing
this before it's all over now I know
what some of you may be thinking well
Danny later tells Tyrion to stay down
into the crypts so he doesn't get
himself killed I know I know it sounds
like everything will be all right but
let's just wait and see how things play
out when Tyrion actually has to face his
sister again let's see how things go
when they start to actually focus on
King's Landing now that Jon Snow has a
claim for the Iron Throne and that Dany
and Sons a conversation did not end so
well I think we will see the foundation
of these relationships really start to
crack once it's time to get the iron
throne you can already see how
conflicted Daenerys is throughout many
of the scenes in the episode now let's
go to the forges of Winterfell where we
get another scene between Arya and gang
jury I know I do have a lot of new
subscribers watching my videos this
season but for all of you who have been
following my channel for a long time
should already know how badly I wanted
Aria and ginjury to not only reunite but
also have a relationship together now I
know there is a age difference between
the two characters but they are both
adults now so I really don't see an
issue I think these scenes are mostly
here just to set up their relationship
now we do get some dialogue about the
army of the dead but this scene is
mostly meant for Aria and ginjury to
continue to connect with each other
there is something about this scene that
I do want to talk about during the
conversation Gendry makes a comment
about the crypts of Winterfell he more
or less says that's where Arya should go
during the battle because they are
definitely much safer than the castle or
the battlefield we hear different
characters say this in the
episode they are definitely one us to
think the Crips of Winterfell are the
safest place to hide this could also be
some foreshadowing maybe they aren't as
safe as everyone thinks even in the
official trailer we could see Varys and
Gilly hiding down there but we also see
Varys looking up as if he can hear all
the chaos right above him that could be
another sign that the castle gets
overtaken by the whites there was even
that trailer where we could see John
Arya and Sansa down there when the night
Kings cold air comes creeping into their
vault maybe the army of the Dead make it
inside the crypts of Winterfell causing
everyone to find the secret tunnels that
are down there somewhere we have heard
characters mention them before we'll
make it to the wall I won't make it 10
feet past the Winterfell gates always
hidden passageways built so the Lords of
Winterfell could escape the road will be
dangerous how can I help you
come with us when we ride south none of
us know the castle as well as you do
it's hidden tunnels its weaknesses its
people Winterfell was your home once we
may have to see everyone leave
Winterfell to fight another day
now in this Aria and Gander II scene I
do have to say that I am a little
worried about how confident Aria is we
all know what Aria has been through we
know she isn't easily scared but her
confidence is off the charts I know she
has had to hurt John talk about the army
of the Dead
and she has definitely seen what her
brother bran has turned into I just hope
they aren't setting up Aria as this
ultimate badass just to see her get
taken out during the battle it's almost
as if she's under estimating the army
the dead in a very similar way that
Cersei is under estimating them I also
know some fans did not like Arya and
Gendry sex scene together and I do
understand why some fans still see her
as Arya from the earlier seasons but I
don't see it that way it would be very
different if this happened back in
season 3 but the Arya that I see on the
screen looks old enough to do whatever
the hell she wants now it's time to go
into the godswood where we get one of
the most anticipated reunions and Game
of Thrones history Jaime Lannister
finally gets a chance to talk to Brian
stark alone the scene kind of went the
way that I thought it would Jamie said
he was sorry and bran said yeah whatever
none of that matters now
Jaime was wondering why bran kept his
mouth shut about what happened bran
basically said I can't let them kill you
because we need you during the battle so
Jaime says what about after the battle
bran says how do you know there will be
and after then Jamie goes and gets his
brown pants
unfortunately Jaime may not make it out
of the battle alive bran may already
know this like I said in my other videos
Jaime may end up sacrificing himself for
one of the Starks then he may end up
dying in the arms of the woman that he
loves
what's his Brienne that could have been
why we got that amazing scene between
Jaime and Brienne near the end of the
episode that may have been the closure
between those two characters Jaime
showed his love for Brienne without
actually coming out and saying it and
Brienne kind of did that too when she
stood up for Jaime in front of everyone
else now that I think about it a damn
near cried during both of their scenes
together because after Jamie talks to
brain in the godswood he sees Brienne
out in the field they
have some small talk at first but then
bran just comes out and says it what are
you doing here why are you standing here
basically talking about nothing why did
you come over here what do you want to
say you know that both Jaime and Brienne
really want to tell each other exactly
how they feel but they haven't had that
kind of a relationship where they
express their feelings for one another
at least not in that way
Jaime wants to say more than he does but
he ends up just saying that he's not the
fighter that he once was but it would be
an honor to serve under her command as
we all know Jaime is now a broken man he
doesn't have much left in the tank but
what he does have he has given it all to
Brienne take me as I am and Brienne does
except he has given her the respect that
she deserves
Jaime used to be the man at the head of
an army now he's willing to serve under
Brienne he wants to serve under Brienne
he knows that she can lead them to a
victory now I know I am jumping around
scenes here but when Jaime Knights
Brienne
that was just a beautiful scene I got
very emotional when that happened I
loved Jaime and Brienne his characters
for a very long time they were kind of
like the complete opposites of one
another
Brienne was the definition of a knight
no one deserved it more than she did but
then you had Jamie who was already a
knight but he was a man without honor
it's very satisfying to see how far he
has came because Brienne does say in
this episode Jamie is a man of honor he
saved my life in a way Brienne actually
gave Jamie's life some meaning it was
her that showed him he could serve a
purpose he did not have to live up to
the Kingslayer persona Noah did take
Jamie a long time to see that but he has
Brienne to thank what she does he
finally gives her the recognition she
deserves can you think of a better
character to be the one to do that for
Brienne
other than Jaime the man that we all
know she loves although she already
honored all the duties of a knight she
is now officially a knight of the Seven
Kingdoms
which was also the name of the episode
as I said before this was an amazing
scene for Brienne and Jaime but I think
this also means one of them dies in the
next episode
after Jaime and bran talk in the
godswood right before Jamie talks to
Brienne he first has a conversation with
his brother during this scene Tyrion
does say we're gonna die at Winterfell
only I don't think Tyrion is meant to
die at that battle his story has never
about the army of the dead well neither
has Jaime's in all honesty but his story
is about Redemption
he started out as a man who was hated by
just about everyone now he is on a crash
course of getting that Redemption and I
do think he could very well die at
Winterfell essentially the same location
his story started
now he's back here again at the end of
the story ready to give his life in
service of House Stark he is ready to
lay it all on the line again because he
did risk his life by killing the Mad
King to save as many as he possibly can
if he dies in this battle in the arms of
Brienne I think that would be a great
ending for Jaime Lannister's story I
could accept that as a fan of his
character there is one other thing that
I want to add remember how Jaime said
that any Knight can make a knight
well now that Brienne is a knight
herself I think she may end up doing the
same thing for Podrick assuming both of
them survive we have already seen how
much better he has gotten with a sword
Brienne has also spent a significant
amount of time with him he has been
ride-or-die with Brienne ever since they
started travelling together I think we
may even see him save Brienne at some
time during the battle remember he did
the same thing for Tyrion at the Battle
of Blackwater Bay so I think we could
see him do the same thing for Brienne
and if she does survive the battle I
think she can make him a knight as well
now I want to go to the Sansa and Danny
scene this is when they have their
conversation about John in the future of
the north first I do want to say I have
a very close eye on Sansa and yon Royce
has anyone else noticed that these two
characters are always together talking
when no one else is around I wonder what
they're really up to
I wonder if they're making any
arrangements for the future of house
Arryn and House Stark let us not forget
songs and sweet Robin were very close to
getting married once before well I'm
lord of the Vale when I grow up I'll be
able to fly anybody who bothers me or
you when we get married you can tell me
if you don't like somebody and then we
can bring them back here and whoosh
right through the moon door
and I found that the veil could also be
a safe location to hide if the army of
the Dead do take over Winterfell no I
don't want to get ahead of myself but I
am wondering what they're up to
anyways songs and Danny okay at first it
did look like these two were about to
find some common ground because they
both do care about John but then
everything changes because sanso wants
answers I actually really enjoyed Songza
getting a little aggressive here
sometimes I do get annoyed when songs
acts like that but I understand where
she was coming from in this situation
what does Danny intend to do with the
north one and if she takes the Iron
Throne
Sansa wants them to be independent
unfortunately we never get to hear
Danny's answer but that might be setting
up a second fight for the Iron Throne
now think about John and Danny's scene
in the crypts of Winterfell did I not
say John should wait until after the
battle was over to say something to
Danny why the hell would he do this now
anyways now Danny knows who John is she
found out Rhaegar and Lyanna got married
and they had a son who is Jon Snow aka
Aegon Targaryen next in line for the
Iron Throne this was pretty much the
last thing Daenerys ever wanted someone
to say to her this entire time she
thought she was the last living
Targaryen she thought she was next in
line for the Iron Throne now you would
think Danny would be a little happy to
find out she still has some family
around but that did not even cross her
mind she is now wondering what Jon's
intentions really are when John said how
he found out Danny did find it very
convenient that the only two people that
are now saying this just so happened to
be John's brother and his best friend
now she might be thinking are John
Shawn's a Sam brand Tyrion and God knows
who else trying to take the Iron Throne
away from me what the hell is happening
everything is about to crumble also do
you remember that scene from one of the
recent trailers there was a scene where
we could see John and Danny in a room
together Daenerys has her back turned to
John almost as if she doesn't even want
to look at him then we see John get
ready to leave the room and Danny never
looks back
I'm wondering if they're setting up a
second fight for the Iron Throne not
just against Cersei but also something
between Dany John and even Sansa now
imagine if Danny loses most of her
soldiers in the battle for Winterfell
there is also a chance she could lose
more dry
as well what if John and/or Sansa have
more support than Danny does after the
battle is over
even if John doesn't want the Iron
Throne for himself everyone could still
rise up to claim it for the north or
whoever else they wanted if you remember
bran stark and Danny both have a vision
of King's Landing where it looks like a
major battle has taken place the Iron
Throne is covered in snow in Danny's
vision she does walk up to the Iron
Throne to claim it for herself only she
never does I've always said this could
be foreshadowing Danny's future she may
never sit on the Iron Throne then of
course you have Jenny song this was also
included in the episode this is the song
that you can hear Podrick sing basically
what happens is there was a character
named Duncan Targaryen obviously a
descendant of both John and Danny
well this character ends up giving his
claim to the Iron Throne for love he
marries Jenny of old stones
unfortunately their story ends in
tragedy both of them died in a fire at
Summer Hall now there are some theories
that maybe Jenny of old stones is the
ghost of high heart but I don't want to
get into all of that so what does this
song say about John and Danny could this
be foreshadowing John or Danny giving up
their claim to the Iron Throne for love
not so strong what is honor compared to
a woman's what is Duty against the feel
[Music]
well I have always said that I don't
think John will want to sit on the Iron
Throne and I don't think Danny will ever
sit on the Iron Throne either based on
her vision at the house of the undying
if that song is foreshadowing the fate
of John and Danny then their love story
may end in a tragedy as well now back to
Danny and songs have seen Danny ends up
getting kind of slighted again when
Theon Greyjoy shows up now before I get
into that I do just want to say this was
another emotional scene for me
Theon Greyjoy is another character that
I did not like at one time but he has
grown on me over the years and I am now
enjoying his own Redemption story I
actually had more of an emotional
connection to this reunion than I did
John and arias and that's crazy because
that was the one I was looking forward
to the
most anyways beyond tells Danny what's
up yaar is okay and she's heading to the
Iron Islands Danny says well why are you
here feel and then looks at Sansa and
says I want to fight for Winterfell if
you will have me lady Sansa this is
right in front of Danny so she is
getting to see the love for Sansa and
the support for Sansa now I know that
Theon doesn't add much to the army but
it is just another example of Danny
feeling this disconnect with all the
other characters Danny is the outsider
almost as much as her Dothraki and
unsullied or maybe even more so because
her father is responsible for killing
Ned Stark's father and brother not to
mention everyone still thinks Danny's
brother Rhaegar kidnapped and raped
Liana Danny's not feeling the love even
though she's there to save everyone now
I was actually getting worried there
wasn't gonna be much of a story to tell
at Winterfell besides everyone meeting
up again and fighting the dead but I do
think they're doing a very good job at
keeping things interesting in between
all the battles I think this next scene
is one of the most underrated scenes
from the episode this is when Davos and
Gilly see a little girl that is very
reminiscent of Shireen at first I just
thought damn I know Davos has to be
missing Shireen at that moment because I
know I was then during my second watch I
remembered that Shireen was helping
Gilly learn how to read so I really
liked that they added her to the scene
not only does it give Gilly an
opportunity to get some screen time but
she can also relate to that child
Gilly is still a wildling at heart so
she probably feels more comfortable
around the small folk or common folk
then she does all the High Lords and
ladies I also saw some fans saying that
could be Melisandre hiding her identity
but I don't think that's the case here I
think it would be really screwed up if
Melisandre came back as someone that
reminded everyone of Shireen the child
she burned to death also there is no
evidence that Melisandre can change her
body size so drastically we've only seen
her as an old woman so I doubt she can
transform into a small child that's just
my opinion the next scene is one dollar
has said beric Dondarrion and tormund
Giantsbane arrive at Winterfell now let
me tell you tormund Giantsbane was
absolutely hilarious during the entire
episode he made me laugh out loud
several times this dude is excellent at
being the comedy relief in the show
I loved how they did this scene when
John sees dollar I said again the music
starts and things are getting emotional
then as soon as John is about to give
him a hug here comes this big son of a
[ __ ] slam and writing to John to stop
the music I thought that was well done
because that's exactly what he would do
anyways they find out everyone is dead
whoever isn't at Winterfell already is
now in the night king's army so it
should be even bigger than we originally
thought we also find out the night Kings
army will arrive before the Sun comes up
again so shits about to get crazy
the next scene is when they all
strategize how they will defeat the
night king now I already made an entire
video based on that scene alone so I
don't want to go over everything again
basically I don't think the night king
will fall into their trap so easily
he was created thousands of years ago so
he's had a lot of time to think about
his own strategy I also think the night
King is a green seer like bran Stark
which means he may be able to see what
all of them are doing as well there is
always a chance the night King doesn't
even go to Winterfell himself he could
go elsewhere while his army attacks the
Starks Castle however I still believe
the night king could die at this battle
I have made a lot of videos on this
subject already since the Starks have
such a close connection to the night
king and the White Walkers I always felt
like this is where the battle should end
but on the other hand who really knows
every time I start to get confident
about my theory something else happens
that makes me start to second-guess it
either way all my chips are in the
center of the table I have invested so
much into this battle for Winterfell
hopefully some of my theory surrounding
the battle do come true I guess we shall
see in the very next episode now there
is something I do want to mention about
the scene when everyone leaves the room
Tyrion Lannister stays behind to talk to
Brian Stark he wants to know about his
journey
obviously brain is no longer that little
kid Tyrion once knew back in the first
season at first a bran really doesn't
want to say anything because it's such a
long story but Tyrion reminds him they
really don't have much else to do but
sit around and wait for the army of the
dead this is where the scene ends we're
not sure if brain said anything at all
but later in the episode Tyrion does say
something that could suggest otherwise
Tyrion all of a sudden becomes very
optimistic he says I think we will live
when our
Tyrion said to Jamie we're gonna die at
Winterfell so I do wonder what bran
might have said I wonder if he made a
comment to Tyrion kind of like you did
to Jamie in the godswood when Jamie and
brain spoke he basically indicated Jamie
might not survive the battle but maybe
he said the opposite to Tyrion maybe he
said something that led Tyrion to
believe in he is gonna survive unlike
his brother Jamie then we get a scene
where grey worm and missandei foreshadow
one of their deaths as I said before one
of them will not make it out of the next
episode I think it's gonna be great will
most likely be right on the front lines
of the battlefield
also we finally got to see ghosts now it
would have been nice if we could have
actually seen Jon greet him when he got
there but at least we got to see him at
all I'm hoping they don't kill ghosts
during the battle I'm worried they might
get rid of him because they don't want
to spend money on ghosts for whatever
reason
hopefully Jon locks him up down in the
crypts of Winterfell now I know they
might need him during the battle but I
think everything's gonna be too crazy
for him to survive but that's my opinion
now I did enjoy the scene of Jon Sam and
Delores said it was very reminiscent of
their days at Castle black here they are
again as the Watchers on the wall
waiting for the dead to arrive at their
gate it's really sad because this might
be the last time we see these three
characters together again
I don't think dollar as said survives
the battle we hear him say once again
the last man alive needs to burn the
rest I'm afraid he will be the one to
die out of these three another character
I said would die in the battle is beric
Dondarrion I think he dies when he saves
the hounds life they have another scene
together on the battlements of
Winterfell in this episode we saw them
together again in the episode 3 trailer
so it does seem like these two will
spend most of the battle together like I
said since barrack has been so closely
connected to House Clegane ever since
season 1 I think he ends up giving his
life for Sandor then Sandor will go on
to face his brother in King's Landing in
that scene of barrack the hound and Arya
Stark we do get a nice little moment
when the Hound says he did fight for
Arya once it wasn't much but I did like
that
hopefully the Hound gets a chance to do
that again during the battle I would
like to see him in Arya fighting the
dead together that would be badass at
the end of the episode we finally see
the dead getting very close to the
castle
there was no sign of the night king but
like I said in another video he will
most likely make a very dramatic
entrance into the battle we do however
see a shitload of White Walkers right
before this final-season started I did
make a video where I talked about
everything we should expect to see
during the battle in that video I said
we could see upwards of 90 White Walkers
because Craster did say he had 99 sons
therefore the night King most likely got
all of those sons sacrificed to him we
have seen a couple characters kill some
of those White Walkers already but it
does look like the night king still has
the rest this is an absolutely
terrifying sight not only does he have
that many White Walkers but all of them
are mounted on horses which makes it
even harder the stalk and all of them
also look to have their own magical ice
weapon like we've seen them carry before
Daenerys and John will have to be very
careful when taking the dragons into the
fight
all of these White Walkers could start
throwing their ice weapons at the dragon
as soon as they enter the battle they
might not even need the night king to
kill another dragon when you have that
many White Walkers everyone that has a
Valyrian steel sword will have to kill
several White Walkers each now I know
dragonglass works too but we are gonna
see some badass sword fights between our
main characters who have Valyrian steel
in these White Walkers that have ice
weapons I'm very excited for the next
episode let me know all your thoughts
down below I want to thank everyone for
watching the video I appreciate that as
always and I also want to thank everyone
on patreon for supporting the channel
have a great day I'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you